♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden today attended
the White House Easter Egg Roll.
However, due to inflation, the
kids all had to share one egg.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
I'm gonna need that back,
guys, too.
New York mayor Eric Adams
recently tested positive
for the coronavirus,
and it's the first
positive result he's had.
[ Laughter ]
New Jersey is set this week
to begin allowing the sale
of recreational marijuana,
so now when people drive
into Jersey, instead of,
"What's that smell?"
They'll be saying,
"Ooh, what's that smell?"
[ Laughter ]
The Florida Department
of Education announced last week
that the state has rejected
over 50 math textbooks
from next school year's
curriculum due to references
to critical race theory.
What kind of word problems
do those books have?
"If Johnny has to buy 30 apples
for the Black Panther
meetings..."
[ Laughter ]
The Boston Marathon
was held today.
It's the only marathon that
starts with someone yelling --
[ Boston accent ]
"Cops are here!"
[ Laughter ]
A Florida man
was arrested recently
after authorities found a baby
alligator, firearms, and drugs
in his car
during a traffic stop,
so they had to cancel
the gender reveal party.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Spain recently
detained a fishing boat
that was carrying more
than 6,000 pounds of cocaine
in a fuel tank, which was dumb,
because they could have gotten
way more for the fuel.
[ Laughter ]
The athletic apparel company
Lululemon
will launch a program this week
where customers can exchange
their gently used clothing items
for e-gift cards.
Or, if you prefer cash,
there's always Gary.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, hey, before you go
in the store, I'll pay double.
Gently used, super used. Eh.
Gary's not picky
is what I'm saying."
And finally, a man in Florida
recently broke
a Guinness World Record
by watching the movie
"Spider-Man: No Way Home"
292 times,
and then set another
world record
by watching "Morbius" twice.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
In a new interview, the Russian
ambassador to the U.S.
said that he hasn't talked
to President Vladimir Putin
since 2017.
"Yes, you have,"
said a houseplant.
[ Laughter ]
After a federal judge
ruled yesterday
that the CDC mask mandate
on public transportation
was unlawful,
New York's MTA announced that it
will still enforce the mandate.
However, you are allowed
to briefly pull the mask down
to smoke weed on the subway car
during the morning rush hour.
[ Laughter ]
In a new special,
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
discussed a red-light therapy
called testicle tanning
that advocates claim
can raise testosterone levels.
Oh, I think there's a place
on the corner that does that.
[ Laughter ]
So you should stop by.
Pretty cool.
New York City, you know.
Tesla CEO Elon Musk said
in a new interview
that he does not own a home
and has just been staying
with friends.
Listen, we know you're lying.
You're a billionaire.
You don't have any friends.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Elon Musk says
that he does not own a home
and has just been staying
with friends.
Man, it's got to be pretty
galling to come home from work
and the world's richest man
is watching "Jeopardy!"
and eating your Cheerios.
[ Laughter ]
That's like Snoop coming over
to bum some weed.
[ Laughter ]
The New York Daily News
published an op-ed yesterday
by disgraced former
Governor Andrew Cuomo,
though it was weird
he put that in his byline.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
a quarter of Americans
said that they would want
a professional biographer
to write the story
of their life,
while some literally
can't get them to stop.
[ Laughter ]
West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin
reportedly told a crowd
at a $5,000-a-plate fundraiser
last month
that he plans to run
for reelection in 2024.
Well, I should hope so.
Although it would be hilarious
to charge people $5,000
for a chicken cutlet
and then announce
your retirement.
[ Laughter ]
"Old Joe is goin' fishin'.
Enjoy the chicken, suckers."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
42% of Americans said
that if they had the chance
to meet their
favorite celebrity,
they would ask for a selfie,
or in my experience,
directions to Times Square.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, sure, anything,
anything for a fan.
Hey, while I'm here,
you want a selfie?
You don't.
Okay.
How about I take a picture
of you?
Just -- No?
Okay.
Right down there."
♪♪
According to a new book,
President Biden proposed
to First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
five times before she
agreed to marry him.
So basically, he proposed
marriage the same way
he ran for President.
[ As Biden ]
How about now?
Okay, how about now?
A growing number
of top Russian officials
are reportedly
starting to question
President Vladimir Putin's
invasion of Ukraine.
Which means there's about to be
a shrinking number
of Russian officials.
[ Laughter ]
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
criticized Disney yesterday
for opposing Florida's
so-called Don't Say Gay bill,
and questioned
what kind of content
the company will now produce,
adding,
"In every episode now,
they're gonna have
Mickey and Pluto going at it."
What are you talking about?
In every episode?
You have to build up
to something like that.
That's season finale stuff.
The FBI recently arrested a man
for participating
in the Capitol attack
after he was turned in
by the driver
of the Uber he took
after the insurrection.
Well, that'll teach him
to give 3-star rating.
[ Laughter ]
Politico this week published
its first election forecast
for the 2022 midterm cycle.
Not to be outdone,
Fox New already called it.
[ Laughter ]
The fast food chain Popeye's
announced plans yesterday
to launch a flagship
in Times Square.
Man, I miss the gritty days
of this city,
when the only place to eat
in Times Square
was the Olive Garden.
[ Laughter ]
And unnamed worker has filed
a labor complaint
that alleges Nintendo violated
their right to unionize.
Well, it wouldn't be
the first time they tried
to sow discord by pitting
tradesmen against each other.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
the legalization of marijuana
lowers the demand
for prescription medication.
I mean, sure, why go
all the way to Duane Reade
when you can just go to Dwayne?
[ Laughter ]
And finally -- thank you
to my drug dealer, Dwayne,
for letting me use his picture,
by the way.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I guess that's
one of the nice things
about, you know, the
decriminalization of it all.
Two years ago, he'd be like,
"No, man."
And now he's like, "No, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know, you can
put my number up, too."
And finally,
in a new interview,
the co-founder
of Arizona Beverages said that
the brand's popular iced tea
will remain priced at 99 cents,
despite inflation,
which sounds amazing
until you see how much they've
shrunk their iced cans.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
After a clip
was released yesterday
of former President Trump
storming out of an interview
with journalist Piers Morgan,
a spokesman for Trump
called the preview
a "pathetic attempt
to revive the career
of a failed television host."
Buddy, you're gonna
have to be more specific.
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
Piers Morgan released
a clip from an interview
with former President Trump
that he claims will be
"the most explosive interview
of the year."
Well, it's certainly
gonna be the sweatiest!
I mean, look --
He looks like Jigsaw
just told him he has an hour
to name all the state capitals.
[ Laughter ]
After the Capitol attack,
Senate Majority Leader --
sorry -- Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
reportedly told --
he was the majority at the time.
[ Laughter ]
No, he wasn't. Was he?
After January 6th, was he?
-Yeah. Before, right?
-Yeah, but on January -- Oh, no,
he wasn't. You know what?
I think the important thing
right now is that this
is good television.
[ Laughter ]
Nobody's gonna argue that.
After the Capitol attack,
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
reportedly told his advisors
that he thought
former President Trump was
responsible for the insurrection
and added,
"The Democrats are going
to take care
of the son of a bitch for us."
Oh, come on, Mitch. You've been
around politics for a long time.
When have the Democrats
ever taken care of anything?
[ Laughter and groans ]
Rudy Giuliani appeared on --
Oh, I'm sorry
you had to find out here.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy Giuliani appeared on
"The Masked Singer" last night
in a jack-in-the-box costume
and sang the song
"Bad to the Bone."
I mean,
that is just unbelievable.
Somebody famous was
on "The Masked Singer"!
[ Laughter ]
The new CNN+ streaming service
is reportedly shutting down
on April 30th
after launching
less than a month ago.
Well, I'm not surprised.
You already have
a 24-hour news channel,
and you couldn't even
fill that with news.
Don't get me wrong.
I'd watch Tucci go anywhere.
The Trump International Hotel
in Washington, D.C.,
is set to be sold
in the coming days
to a Florida-based
investor group
led by this intriguing
mystery man.
[ Laughter ]
Disney World on Tuesday lifted
its remaining mask requirements,
and it is really
freaking out the kids.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Tyranny's over!
[ Laughter ]
The organizers
of the Tony Awards
have issued a warning
to attendees
that this year's ceremony has
a "strict no-violence policy,"
which is obviously a response
to that time
that guy shot
Alexander Hamilton.
[ Laughter ]
People love "Hamilton" so much,
they were, like, "Yeah!"
A man in Canada
recently discovered
through a DNA test
that his biological father
was his former coworker,
though he probably should've
figured it out sooner.
[ Laughter ]
Just, I like when
I have to wait a second
'cause it's a reading joke.
[ Laughter ]
Today was National Tea Day.
Oh, do you guys want some tea?
In that case...
[ Whispering ]
Wally's getting fired later.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm kidding.
I went to the network brass
and I said,
"Either he goes or I go!"
And they're like,
"Have a great day."
And finally,
according to the latest numbers,
by this summer,
Netflix is projected to lose
around 2 million subscribers.
To combat this, they're tweaking
the app a little.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]